you're happily married for 19 years
so I think you're a good man to ask how
do you find love how do you find how do
you date in order to find the love of
your life of a lifetime this is gonna
sound
off
but don't
don't tie yourself down meaning like
don't spend time
[__] with those little mini shrimp
and peeling them every night when you
know you're looking for a lobster yeah
like and so I think what happens a lot
of guys they just they're so busy and
like just getting [__] and going from
here to here to here I was never that
guy I always wanted I always wanted to
find someone who understood me I always
wanted that and so I know granted I
haven't had sex with a lot of chicks but
that's and it's and it's not by choice
I'm saying like maybe there was times I
would have done it but I but I know that
I was always looking for someone to
figure out to get me and then and then I
will say this when you know you know
when you know you know when you think
there's I can't imagine a life without
this person
that that happened to me and I can only
say my experiences I had Leanne I loved
her and and I and I didn't even realize
it and the second she dumped me I went
oh no no no no no oh I I don't get to
live a great life without her she's the
thing that's going to give me a great
life I knew it Undisputed I went for a
run and uh she dumped me I went to my
shower I cried I went to Barnes Noble I
bought men from Venus women from Mars
I've watched Fight Club in my closet I
didn't drink I drink a lot of Nyquil to
sleep and then I went for a hike in
Runyon Canyon I was running back down
Outpost by Ben Affleck's house and and
the sun was setting and I just said hey
God if you're listening
just give me this check back I'll never
[__] it up this is the one I won't [__]
it up I won't cheat I'm not gonna be a
bad dude I want to have kids with her
I'll be there I'll be a great [__]
dude I'll take her out on dates like
I'll love this chick
and I got home and she was in my room in
a sundress yeah and I was like oh [__]
you I didn't know he was real yeah I was
like [__] man give me like one more
night let me do some strange tale real
quick yeah before I commit forever but I
think when you know you know this is so
silly but I follow that in business
like when you know you know and like my
assistant's with us and someone goes how
do you find a good assistant I go when
you know you know like people will show
you who they are uh I can tell you when
I fell in love with my assistant
we were doing a TV show and and that we
worked past dinner and all the dinner
places were closed and he just said hey
I got like four meals I didn't know
which one you'd want so I got four
different meals for you I ordered them
they're up in your room and just let me
know whichever you want I'll take care
of the rest of them yeah and I was like
oh that that dude thinks about other
people before himself he didn't even get
himself dinner he just got me four
dinners and I was like [__] yeah I did
the same thing with my social media
manager
the way she was operating was I was like
I feel like she's thinking about me yeah
and we connected on so many levels on so
many levels I could talk to her about
things and ideas I had and then I was
like okay I want her I want him I want
I think you I think it's got to be that
thing when you know you know and it can
be so simple as like
like a personal trainer or like a
Jujitsu class or like just where you go
oh I'm connecting right now but you have
to allow yourself to notice that
personally you hi I think you do I mean
I think you have to put yourself out
there and you have to be available for
it you know that's the hardest part is
just being available for it
because some people so many people just
want to be busy just dating yeah I just
want to have someone in my life I don't
want to be bored I don't want to what if
I die alone I don't wanna I like just be
available for it uh what is it you said
peeling the baby shrimp yeah when you
could be having a lobster
Lobster's still a lot of work I have to
say yeah but well yeah but it's Lobster
so this is a [__] baby shrimp or like
you ever get you ever get the ones in
Brazil where you just go [__] it'll eat
the shell I don't care anymore
which I'm so [__] hungry you just
handful of lobster like it's popcorn or
maybe shrimp like it's popcorn
I've done that in Vietnam I've done that
I just go it's too much work
so when you're in it what's the secret
to successful marriage
what what do uh women want for pressure
oh [__] that's I'm the wrong guy to
answer that I think how to make love to
a woman by Bert Kreischer how do you
make Loves a Woman I'll tell you how I
do it yeah uh
I go down on her first
make sure she has an orgasm yeah and
then I get my turn and that's over
pretty quick
it's like a it's like your ears pierced
it doesn't feel a little prick and it's
over yeah
I um
I don't know if I've done a great job
keeping her happy I think I keep her
interested like I think I I I
keep her occupied like I'm like a little
bit of a rodeo clown like I don't know I
mean like I I know we're happy right now
I know we're really happy
but I don't know if I ever did
as good a job as she did like she's
always been
like she's always been a gangster like
done did everything just does everything
she does it all she does everything like
[__] everything and she loves it she
just does it and then she shows Love For
You by taking care of you and so like I
have a lot of time just been this like
almost like step and repeat husband
where it's like I come in to take a
picture like hey money Tuesday I'm all
right I'm on the road Wednesday take
care guys or like Travel Channel I lived
for two weeks at a time I left for the
movie for three months so like I don't
know that I've ever done
a bang-up job
I buy it like I go I remember one time I
was just like I don't cheat on her I
don't hit her I don't yell at her I'm a
pretty good fighter I'm a really good
fighter like like I'm good at like going
like Hey we're on the same team Oh you
mean de-escalation I'm really good at
like I'm very self I'm very accountable
I'm very self-correcting like if if
we're in a fight and she points
something out and I go oh you're right I
go [__] you're right about that you're
right you're totally wrong oh in the
moment in the moment I'm really good at
that and my wife's not she's not a good
apologizer like she needs to sleep on an
apology and then she can do it I can
apologize in the moment if I realize I'm
wrong and I'm really quick to find my
fault yeah I look for my fault because I
go tell me what I did
adversely as a parent
I have pulled my daughters aside and
been like yo that wasn't you that was
Mom yeah I'm giving you a heads up
because I don't want because I got
really confused as the kids my dad
always made sure I knew I was wrong
and sometimes I wasn't yeah and then as
a kid you're kind of [__] up you're
like well how do I know if I'm wrong and
I think that raises so I was really good
with my girls going like go
and then and then parenting Georgia
taught me a lot about self-correcting
self-correcting was that my oldest
and only my parented like my dad
parented like just like Raise Your Voice
get up to here that's it no that doesn't
[__] this yeah how come the dogs don't
have goddamn leashes on the collars on
their necks and so with Georgia I had to
learn through therapy
that if the if the consequence is here
and it and the highest it goes is here
then why the [__] wouldn't they lie and
do everything because they go well I
know what it's like to hear but if you
can vary your consequence with a child
and find some conversation in it then
all of a sudden they're like well [__]
well I don't want to lie cause this does
this does suck like I like this I like
where we talk and he says write a
thousand words on why driving around
your kids in a car kids in a car is bad
so threaten extreme violence every once
in a while just to
yeah let them know the dog can [__]
bite yeah the dog can bark the dog can
bite but if you pet him on his belly
he'll wag its tail